Sonne Wellen surfen el sonte an der
Küste El Salvadors lange ein Geheimtipp
für Surfer heute ist der kleine Ort
weltweit bekannt unter einem anderen
Namen Bitcoin beach
der Amerikaner Mike Peterson kam vor 18
Jahren zum Surfen hierher und blieb er
engagierte sich sozial im Ort vor allem
in hophaus eine Projekt für Jugendliche
2019 kam dann der Tag der alles
veränderte eine anonyme Spende in
Bitcoin
eine Auflage war dass wir das Geld nicht
einfach in Dollar wechseln sondern
tatsächlich in Bitcoin ausgeben also
haben wir überlegt wie wir Bitcoin hier
einführen und so auch den Tourismus
angucken
und finanzielle inklusivität fördern
denn die meisten Leute hier haben kein
Bankkonto sie verdienen nicht genug und
haben die nötigen Papiere gar nicht
jetzt können Sie per Bitcoin Geld
empfangen von jemanden im Ort oder
irgendwo auf der Welt
maria hat ein einfaches Restaurant genau
gegenüber von hophaus kein Ort wo man
die finanzielle Zukunft vermuten würde
aber bei ihr kann man mit Bitcoin
bezahlen
am Anfang fand ich es schwierig das zu
benutzen es ist ja etwas ganz Neues das
kann man nicht einfach so von einer
Minute auf die andere
wir fanden es komisch
aber jetzt habe ich mich daran gewöhnt
und finde es einfach
es heißt der Erfolg von Bitcoin Beach
habe El Salvadors Präsidenten naiv
bouquele inspiriert
2021 macht er Bitcoins zur
nationalbildung als erstes Land der Welt
das garantiert Aufmerksamkeit
Finanzpolitik als PR-Maßnahme
[Musik]
Mike sagt das Land profitiert
früher hatten die Leute Angst nach El
Salvador zu kommen jetzt strömen die
Touristen nur so ins Land und wollen ein
Teil davon sein was hier passiert das
narrativ für bei El Salvador hat sich
geändert von Gangs und Morden zu hey das
ist dann der Spitze der finanziellen
Innovation
gekommen um am historischen Moment teil
zu haben
die meisten Leute gar nicht wo El
Salvador ist jetzt ist es auf dem
Radarschirm der ganzen Welt hier wird
Geschichte gemacht
er sagt er benutzt fast nur Bitcoin aber
heute braucht er dann doch etwas Bargeld
aus dem Bitcoin Automaten für den Bus
es klappt nicht ganz reibungslos
ich habe einen Ausdruck mit einem Code
bekommen in 10 Minuten soll ich
wiederkommen und wenn die Transaktion
dann autorisiert ist bekomme ich mein
Geld
Trainer betreibt ein Kaffee im Ort auch
sie weiß dass der Traum von der reinen
bitcoin-wirtschaft noch nicht ganz
funktioniert
viele Leute zahlen für einen Kaffee oder
Saft in meinem Café mit Bitcoin aber
meine Miete kann ich damit nicht
bezahlen da ist es gut dass ich es hier
in Bargeld umtauschen kann
Rene ist aus Deutschland nach Bitcoin
Beach gekommen er schreibt einen
bitcoin-blog und ist Teil einer
Delegation die sich im Land ein Bild
machen davon wie es mit der neuen
Währung klappt dabei darf natürlich ein
Besuch nicht fehlen da wo alles begann
Bitcoin Peaches mittlerweile in fester
Begriff den vermutlich in jedem Land
dieser Welt wird es irgendwelche Bitcoin
ergeben oder irgendwelche Bitcoin
Bitcoin Enthusiasten geben die schon mal
von Bitcoin Beach gehört haben und es
werden ja auch jedes Jahr jede jeden
Monat werden es mehr Leute und ich
glaube dass auch viele dieser Leute die
irgendwann mal davon hören sich
vornehmen einmal auch im Leben
vielleicht hier gewesen zu sein
außerhalb der Bitcoin Oase sonte da wo
ein Großteil der Bevölkerung von der
Hand in den Mund lebt ist von der
schönen neuen kryptowelt allerdings
nicht viel zu spüren nur wenige
Geschäfte nehmen überhaupt Bitcoin wohl
auch weil die Nachfrage gering ist
René und die anderen wollen mithelfen
das zu ändern sie besuchen ein Programm
das Schulkindern die digitale Währung
näher bringen soll und werden gleich als
Abschlussprüfer eingesetzt
Job Celine macht ihre Sache gut sie
besteht den Test
die Technologie ist eine Herausforderung
besonders für ältere die haben ganz
schön damit zu kämpfen jetzt können wir
jungen es Ihnen Schritt für Schritt
erklären dann können Sie auch Bitcoin
benutzen
so meine Haarprodukte iosa
korrektnamente Bitcoin
noch ist joselins Realität aber weit
entfernt von der Welt der
internationalen bitcoins-szene die sich
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt auf der
adopting bitcoin-konferenz trifft auch
René ist dabei alle hier sind voll in
die Krypto Zukunft El Salvadors und
darüber hinaus investiert ich finde es
einfach mutig ich finde es spannend und
ich glaube das auch andere Länder und
andere Volkswirtschaften vielleicht viel
aus diesen diesen initialprojekt jetzt
lernen können kaum Thema die vielen
Risiken die der Club des Space birgt
Kursschwankungen mangelnde Kontrolle
betrug all das lässt ein Salvadors
Bitcoin Politik als riskantes Experiment
erscheinen
Paulo adono ist der CTO der
Handelsplattform bitcoinex arbeitet eng
mit El salvados Regierung zusammen der
Zusammenbruch seines früheren
Konkurrenten FTX kein Grund zur Sorge
diese Band was die kryptoindustrie
anbelangt trennt dieses Ereignis solche
Firmen die sich auf Bitcoin
konzentrieren von denen bei denen es um
reine Spekulation geht
Regulation
hat die richtige Entscheidung getroffen
indem es sich auf Bitcoin konzentriert
statt auf nfts und die ganzen verrückten
instabilen Währungen
nachprüfbar ist das allerdings nicht
Präsident wo Kehle verkündet zwar per
Twitter regelmäßig neue
bitcoin-investitionen doch die Details
bleiben undurchsichtig niemand kann
nachvollziehen was mit den Millionen
öffentlicher Gelder wirklich geschieht
Transparenz es gibt keine offizielle
Autorisierung für den Ankauf von Bitcoin
der Präsident hat selbst auf Twitter
gesagt dass er auf der Toilette Bitcoin
kauft das hat ernsthafte Konsequenzen
vor allem angesichts der großen
Kursverluste
Ruth und ihre Kollegen von der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Christo sei
gehören zu den wenigen die öffentlich
Kritik an der bokele Regierung äußern
das liegt zum einen daran dass der
Präsident beim Großteil der Bevölkerung
sehr beliebt ist aber auch daran dass
Kritiker eingeschüchtert Oppositionelle
verfolgt und unabhängige Medien
unterdrückt werden
jeder der Fragen stellt der Transparenz
verlangt wird von der Regierung
automatisch als Gegner betrachtet das
macht es schwer und kompliziert es gibt
einen ganzen kommunikationsapparat der
die Arbeit von
Menschenrechtsverteidigern stigmatisiert
aber in meinen Augen ist Schweigen keine
Option im Gegenteil wir müssen
denunzieren
mit dem Kampf gegen kriminelle Gangs die
terrorisieren seit vielen Jahren die
salvadorianische Gesellschaft und machen
das Land zu einem der gefährlichsten der
Welt
und gegen sie vorzugehen rief bokele im
März den Ausnahmezustand aus seit der
verlängert er ihn immer wieder Ende
offen
demonstrativ lässt er tausende Männer
verhaften und füllt die Gefängnisse
Razzia der Sondereinsatzkräfte sie
suchen nach bekannten gängenmitgliedern
wir sind ständig auf Patrouille und
durchsuchen Häuser nach Kriminellen
wir haben schon viele erwischt und
eingesperrt andere wiederum sind
abgehauen
die regelmäßigen Einsätze der
antigeneinheiten sollen das
Sicherheitsgefühl in der Bevölkerung
fördern
Hausdurchsuchungen gehören zur
Tagesordnung so steht plötzlich ein
halbes Dutzend schwer bewaffnete
Einsatzkräfte mitten in HWS Wohnzimmer
und will seine Papiere sehen er nimmts
gelassen äußert sogar Unterstützung für
die Politik der Regierung
heute kann ich ohne Angst vors Haus
gehen da drüben wo es den Hang hinauf
geht da war früher eine feindliche Gang
die hätten auf mich geschossen wenn ich
dahin gegangen wäre das hat sich
geändert
andere sind weniger begeistert von der
demonstrativen Präsenz der Staatsmacht
denn bei den Razzien gehen immer wieder
auch Unschuldige ins Netz
Manuel ist Vater von zwei Kindern
arbeitet in einer Fabrik und einer von
Zehntausenden salvadorianern die in den
vergangenen acht Monaten im Gefängnis
gelandet sind dort erlebte er Schläge
Hunger und die Sorge um seine Familie
früher hatte er Angst vor den Gangs und
heute
manchmal ist das Gegenmittel schlimmer
als die Krankheit was ich im Gefängnis
durchgemacht habe war furchtbar
jedes Mal wenn ich rausgehe habe ich
Angst dass ich wieder an diesem Ort
lande ich will dort nie wieder hingehen
mit der Kritik an seine autoritären
Politik nennt sich selbst den coolsten
Diktator der Welt das bitcoin-experiment
gehört wohl auch zum coolen Image doch
das Risiko dabei tragen die Menschen in
El Salvador
noch ist unklar wohin die Welle sie
trägt